sie schreiben reiche sein eine
diskriminierte Minderheit das hat mich
ehrlich gesagt sehr überrascht wie
kommen Sie darauf ich habe geschrieben
es ist eine Minderheit die mit
Vorurteilen und Stereotypen konfrontiert
ist ja weniger so im täglichen erleben
sondern in den in den Medien ja oder
auch in der Politik dass das immer
irgendwie eine Stimmung gemacht wird
gegen reiche ja ich sag ihn jetzt in
meinen Bekanntenkreis sind überwiegend
Unternehmer und ich kenne fast keinen
fast kein der nicht über auswandern
nachdenkt und zwar ernsthaft nachdenkt
das werden jetzt viele nicht tun aus
unterschiedlichen Gründen und warum
denken die über das Auswandern nach
wegen dieser Stimmung ja wegen dieser
Stimmung weil sie sagen ich fühle mich
nicht willkommen ich fühle mich nicht
gewährtchätzt